so do you you count yourself as having
geek street cred I don't know what geek
street cred is I feel like geeking
streak don't make geek lab lab cred I
have you know what I would you in South
Africa did you have sex science teachers
I did I had one of my favorite teachers
and probably my best teacher was my
science teacher mr. Pilate and he was he
just made everything seem simple like he
you know you know when the teachers I
can teach you a thing was not all yeah
and he I I would get better marks at
science than I would at most subjects
and I think it was just he made me
understand what it was all about that's
good yeah that's good so then you became
a community apparently he wasn't
influential or not
well what happened actually was my math
teacher was horrible and so because my
math teacher failed man cancelled out no
and then I couldn't I couldn't go and
study in university I couldn't do
because they were in South Africa if you
don't do math you can't do science
anymore and so because I failed at math
they they basically went you fail at
science and I should get an A for
science I could have been you but it
seemed math is the language of the
universe so there's what I was speaking
of dialects how does that work I was
passing a science that's all I know and
you just sent me back I couldn't speak a
language of the universe so you weren't
the comedian track instead of the
scientist track yes no that's good so
but how about just general geek are you
geek sympathizer I don't know I feel
like geeks run the universe look at you
I mean you have your number one on the
books selling this geeks are running
Silicon Valley Rich's running TV shows
the richest people in the world I don't
think you need sympathy if you're a geek
now I feel like it's the other way
around because imagine if you are on the
cusp of geek vs. chalkiness yeah right
those are time when jock was everything
yes and they give us wedgies right and
then what happened was geek all of a
sudden tipped that yeah because the
jocks needed us to fix their computers
but now what imagine if you were jock
chest protector like and then you just
just chucked at the wrong time Oh that'd
be bad imagine that you're homeless now
and you've gone right now you're
struggling and then you're like man I
used to give that guy wedgies
I'd like that verb shocked at the ruins
that he jerked at the wrong time you
could have geeked at the wrong time you
could have jumped mine even kicked in
the duck
that's the wrong time look he brought
total wrong the worst time to go yeah
Majan you trying to be a scientist in
the duck house no I'd be burned upside
down at the stake and just because you
were black know that would it be like
most of it and then they'd be like oh
yeah and he was a scientist I don't even
know what that was I'm glad we burned
him hey did you like that cool video huh
well how about a bunch of cool videos
all commercial free plus exclusive
original content that you can't find
anyplace else all on Startalk all-access
calm